I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Season two, episode seven, The Client. The Client! Welcome to Office, ladies, everyone. I am still putting my note cards on the table. This is more note cards than I've ever seen you have, ever. Jenna, I take my job very seriously. I am keeper of the
note cards. First of her name. It's Game of Thrones, Jenna. I'm keeper of the note cards. Angela, you know I don't know that show. Well, I'm gonna quote it at you. You are the rest of my life. Okay, where are we at? Let's get started. This episode was written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Greg Daniels. You have nothing to say to that? You don't have it? You've got a gazillion note cards, but nothing to say to that. I mean, listen, sometimes you say things that are just facts. That's just a fact. I don't know what to do with that. So like, yes, that is true, Jenna. That is a true statement. That is who wrote this and who directed
this. Next. Okay, well, I guess next I usually do a summary. Yeah. But I'm not gonna do it today. Why? Because I don't maybe like, I don't like that you're not responding to me today. No, I'm kidding. But I'm not gonna do the summary today because I got someone else to do the summary. Who? I don't know. Is it somebody? Is it your husband Lee? It's not my husband Lee. I'm gonna let you listen. Alright, hit play, Sam. In the client, Michael heads to Chili's with Jam to try and close the deal with a major client. While Michael is gone, Pam discovers a screenplay Michael has been writing called Threat Level Midnight, an action movie about an FBI agent named
Michael Scarn, who is married to, yours truly, Catherine Zeta-Jones. The star divides up the roles and reads the script aloud. Also, in this episode, Jim and Pam share grilled cheese sandwiches on the rooftop of Dunder Mifflin and Michael and Jan share a kiss. Oh my god. Holy crap, balls. Is that Catherine Zeta-Jones? That is Catherine Zeta-Jones. You are freaking kidding me. I am not. I am not. What the hell? What? What the hell? What is going on? Yes, should I explain? Yeah. Yeah. Alright, I've never met her. I should start with that. What? Did you not know that? We've never met. No, I didn't know that. Yeah. In my mind, you're like, you have this whole
friendship with like a big movie star and I'm like, oh, that's cool Jenna, I guess, whatever. Well, I'd like to say I would love to be friends with her. Yeah. She has a love of movie musicals, like traditional movie musicals. She's so good herself. She's so fantastic. But I also have that love. So I have daydreams of us watching like old movie musicals together and then tap dancing a little bit and then maybe having a cocktail or some tea. Reenacting scenes from Chicago. Yeah, this is what I imagine my friendship with Catherine Zeta-Jones is like. But I did do a movie with Michael Douglas. I played his daughter in a movie called Solitary Man. He's so good in it. It stars him and Jesse
Eisenberg. In that movie, I did my first New York City walk and talk. Do you know those movies you see that are shot in New York and they're just people, they're just walking and talking. And from the time I was little, I would see this in movies and that to me was like, you're a movie star. Doing a walk and talk. If you do a walk and talk on the streets of New York, you've made it kid. So I'm shooting this scene with Michael Douglas and I turned to him and I said, Michael, this is my first New York City walk and talk. And he turned to me. He got it. He goes, what? You got to be kidding me. This is fantastic. I'm your first New York City walk and talk. Congrats. It was everything I wanted the moment
Eisenberg. In that movie, I did my first New York City walk and talk. Do you know those movies you see that are shot in New York and they're just people, they're just walking and talking. And from the time I was little, I would see this in movies and that to me was like, you're a movie star. Doing a walk and talk. If you do a walk and talk on the streets of New York, you've made it kid. So I'm shooting this scene with Michael Douglas and I turned to him and I said, Michael, this is my first New York City walk and talk. And he turned to him. He got it. He goes, what? You got to be kidding me. This is fantastic. I'm your first New York City walk and talk. Congrats. It was everything I wanted the moment
to be. Well, so flash forward to I'm on the office and they write this joke in this episode that Michael Skarn's wife is Catherine Zeta-Jones cut even more forward. Their kids are now, I think, big fans of the office and she started posting about the office. So I got up the courage to DM her on Insta. He slid into Catherine Zeta-Jones DMs. I did. And we've had a nice little DM relationship ever since and then I became brave enough to ask her if she would please, please record our summary. And that brings us to now. Okay. Well, Catherine, I don't know you, but that was fantastic. And thank you so much. Thank you. Now can I go into fast facts? Please go into your fast facts. Fast fact. Number one, big news, everybody.
Big news at two minutes, 50 seconds. Mindy's hair is down. Why do you want to frickin steal one of my big note cards? Damn it, Jenna. That's my running, my running bit about Mindy's hair. Your running bit? My running bit. It's not our running bit. It's mine. Oh, I have to admit it is kind of yours. You started it. Okay. Yes. It's a half up, half down. But it's very flowy. Very flowy. We are starting our transition to all down. This is half up, half down because in Halloween, there were these braids, but you said it didn't count because it was a costume. That's right. And I also claimed that I thought the first time we were going to see her hair down was casino night. So I stand corrected. It is two minutes, 50 seconds, the client. The client.
Also in that scene, I think we're getting closer to the Kelly Kapoor we will all know and love. Oh, she was giggly. She was like, say it's not your fiance. Yes. Right. Giggly. Yes. No more morose. French twist. Kelly Kapoor. So for those of you who've been listening to the podcast here, you know why this fast fact was so big for Jenna and I. Kelly's hair is almost all the way down. We've been tracking her transformation. When will she become Mindy? We're almost there. Speaking of hair, what is up with John's hair in this episode? Did you notice? Well, it's like it kind of like is flipping out a little. No, the front like the bangs that are usually kind of like sloppy and real cute. They're like shellacked a little bit. Well,
it looks like someone just took a pair of scissors and just did a real blunt horizontal cut. Well, I have said, I feel like he has a bowl haircut. Yeah. This is the most bowl I've ever seen. So guys, you can check that out. Yeah. Fast fact number two, Tim Meadows. Guest stars in this episode as the Lackawanna County representative Christian. I feel like, you know, we had this rule where we weren't going to do any stunt casting and this is the first time we kind of broke that rule, but we had to because he was so good. He's so good. And actually, Jen and I both know Tim and I was able to connect with him this week and we hopped on the phone and talked about this episode and he was so delightful. So I have some fun Tim tidbits for
this episode and I'll get to those here in a minute. Well, I didn't work the day that they shot the scenes with Tim, but I was such a big SNL fan that I went up to the set just to meet him and I had lunch with him. I was, I totally fangirled and eventually we would end up doing the movie Walk Hard together. And so I actually got to work with him, talk about fangirl. I did a pilot with Tim Meadows for Fox called the Gabriel's and Rob Riggle was in it and we had so much fun. He is so hilarious. He's a hoot. Did I just say he's a hoot? Am I a nerd? You did say he is a hoot. Why don't you give us a fast fact? Fast fact number three, this episode was inspired by an idea that they had in the writer's room early on that Jim and Pam would go on a date without really
being on a date. So that was the card that they put up on the wall. How can we get Jim and Pam on a date without really being on a date? But then they also wanted to do the same thing with Michael and Jan. They thought it would be really fun to have both of these couples have this romantic evening. Right. So to have a, have a convention within the work day that they would somehow end up on a date. They also had the end of this episode written first and then they wrote toward that ending. So that look that you see between Jim and Michael at the very end of the episode where they both kind of shrug together like the ladies, the ladies in our lives. They knew that that would be the ending and then they tracked it back. Interesting. Because another thing that they
wanted was this moment where Jim and Michael relate and bond over something. So that's what they decided it would be. Those are my fast facts. Okay. Can I start my note cards? I think we have to take a break. What is with you today? What is with you? What is going on? I don't know. We are taping this like two days before the Christmas holiday week. I am in check it off the list mode. It is pretty funny though because you're saying something and then I'm just looking at you and you're like, that's it. You got nothing. I know you're just staring at me or nodding and I'm like, it's, it's an audio show. You have to give some audio cue that you've heard me. Are you done? Okay. All right. We're going to a break. I did it. I did it. I did it. I did it.
Hey, we have a pretty special guest in this episode. We do. Coming up after the break, we're going to talk to Melora Hardin. Who plays Jan? Yeah. We had to talk to her because we were not at the Chili's. No. So we had no firsthand knowledge of the Chili's, of the kissing. That smooch. We had to go straight to the source. So when we get back from the break, we're going to talk to Melora. Yay. All right, Angel, let's call Melora. Let's call her. Sam, call Melora. Hello. Melora. Hello. Hi guys. Hi. Hi. How are you? Oh man, we're great. It's so great to hear your voice. Nice to hear yours too. It's been a long time. Melora, thank you so much for agreeing to do this. The fans are going to go crazy. Let's get started by asking you, how did you end up on the
office? That's hilarious. Well, I got called last minute. It was sort of a last minute like come in and read for this, which I did. And I remember that, you know, I went in and like, you know, literally looked at the side right there before I went in because it was that last minute. Wow. You know, it was like Ken Qopas was in the room and so was Greg Daniels. And, you know, I could feel everybody was kind of excited. And Allison Jones, our casting director, you know, you can always feel that as an actor, right? When it goes well and people are responding to what you're doing. Sure. And then the next day, I was testing for a pilot and Allison Jones was casting that as well. She came out into the hallway and I was about to go in for my test. And I was like, oh, that was
really fun yesterday. I really like that, you know, those sides. And she's like, yeah. And I said, maybe I'll get, you know, maybe I'll get them both because that was the character of Jan at the time for the pilot was a guest star, possibly recurring character. But this one that I was testing for was a lead character, regular in a pilot. For an actor, you want to get the pilot because, you know, when you're the regular or the one of the stars of the show, because that's better money and, you know, just seems better. And she's like, well, I really want you to get that one, meaning the office. She really wanted me to get the office. Anyway, I went in and I did the pilot test. I didn't get the pilot test, but I did get the office. Wow. Well, the client
is a very big episode for Michael and Jan. Oh, yeah. You know, this is where you have your smooch in the parking lot. And we have a fan who wrote in his name is Ryan and he asked, how far in advance did you know about Michael and Jan's relationship? Well, when we were filming the pilot, I remember sitting at the tables having lunch with Greg Daniels and Steve Carell. And we were all laughing at how kind of weirdly interesting Jan and Michael were together. Like we sort of, and we were like, well, yeah, that's funny. You know, if we get it, if we get it, if we get a pickup and we get an opportunity to do this more of this show than just, you know, the six that we're doing, which was our first season, then, you know, it'll be fun. We should,
we should have them hook up. Wow. Because we kind of felt like there was a little spark between them. And we kind of conjured it on the pilot. Well, you guys had fantastic chemistry. And I think they were all picking up on that and seeing the possibilities because you and Steve and scenes together were just amazing. Thank you. You know what else is like, everybody is so perfectly cast in this show. I mean, that's one of the things I think that makes the show, besides the writing, which is unbelievable, but also just every single person is perfectly cast. There's not one person that you look at and go, well, you know, I mean, I mean, everybody's just absolutely spot on. I agree. I agree. Jinx. Okay. Well, Malora, can we ask you a little bit about
what it was like filming those scenes and that chilies? I mean, how did you get through those scenes? I was dying laughing. Oh, it is ridiculous. I will say that the stuff that Steve and Tim Meadows, he's actually a friend of ours. He was so great in that. He is so freaking funny. And the stuff that they did and the improv that they did and it just, it just flattened me. And I swear, last night when I was watching it, I watched it with my husband and, you know, I was just like, I kept going, oh my God, it was so hard to keep my straight. Oh my God, it was so hard to keep. I was so amazed at how incredibly straight faced I was because I'm telling you, every time we cut, I would just burst into laughter. And I had to look so irritated
and so, you know, so like just completely put off by all the stuff they were doing. But in reality, it was tough. So do you remember anything in particular that those guys improvised? Like was the baby back ribs song? Was that improvised? Yes, I think that was that whole little section there was really, I think that really was just spur of the moment, the way that they kind of went back and forth. Well, I have to move us along. Yes, we have another fan question that I'm actually dying to hear because when I rewatched it, I was like, oh my God, I forgot how long you and Steve kissed. You really smooched quite a bit. David R. Carroll said, BJ Novak has been quoted as saying that the kiss between Michael and Jan was rehearsed and filmed many, many, many times.
I don't remember rehearsing it. I'm certain that when we rehearsed it, we certainly didn't kiss during the rehearsal. No. And actually, last night when I watched it, I was like, that was a really sweet and like kind of awkwardly, just bumpy, bumbly kiss that I kind of loved. I thought it was a really great first kiss for the two of them. Yeah. Do you remember any direction that Greg gave you during that scene? I don't remember. I really think we did it like one time or two times. I don't even know what he is talking about. I remember it being really quick. And I actually think that the take that you see on there is the first time we did it. So I feel like, and it just has all that. It has everything it needs in it. It has the tension. It has the kind of like,
wait, that's so wrong. And wait a second. I want more of that kind of thing that Jan, I think, struggled with the entire relationship with Michael. So I love that. Well, that was really a spy shot. I know that Randall was crouched behind a car and he had this idea of shooting through the car window to you. That's right. And I remember doing some scenes like that. And they always felt so real because you couldn't feel the camera, you know, a foot away from you. You really felt like you were out in a parking lot. Exactly. You really do feel like you're in the middle of nowhere doing your own thing, having that private moment that we're all trying to strive for at all times as actors.
Well, Malora, there is a scene in the Chili's I thought you did such a phenomenal job in. It's at the end of the night and you guys, you've had a few drinks, you're over it. They're having beers and talking and you're just sort of checked out. And then you realize that Michael is about to close the deal. You see what he's doing and you perk up and you look at him with this smile on your face. And it, that was the moment for me that I realized why she even entertained being in a relationship with Michael. She saw that side of him and was like, Oh my God, he's crushing it. And it totally made everything make sense for me. Yeah, but you did a great job. It is a great moment. And it's,
Jan really rarely smiles in the show. I do so much scowling and kind of, you know, a disapproving look. And so it's really, it's really nice to see her kind of have that big full expression of, you know, kind of enjoyment of, Oh my God, this whole thing that, you know, that he's been doing all night that I thought was just a bunch of BS actually was, you know, there was a method to his madness. And I do love that. And I think that is the thing that leads to the kiss is that he feels the, you know, he gets to have the moment of, of the victory. And, and she has, you know, and she kind of is like, Oh, there's more, there's more to this guy than I thought, you know, he's not just this idiot that I thought he was.
Yeah, yeah. Melara, thank you so much for taking the time to talk to us about this. Will you consider coming back for future episodes, perhaps? Oh, sure. Well, when you get to the dinner party, that is why I was going to say, I mean, it is, I mean, it is like one of the best episodes ever. And you're so phenomenal in it. And Melara, what are you up to now? Can we give you a little shout out? Oh, you're sweet. Well, I mean, I'm doing the fourth season of a series that I've been starring on for a while called the bold type. And I just directed an episode for season four. So I'm currently editing that episode. So that's exciting. And I love everybody to
check that out. That's episode 12 of season four, but they can watch the bold type seasons one, two and three streaming on Hulu and on freeform.com now. And also season four begins airing on January 23rd on freeform. So everyone go check out the bold type on Hulu and freeform. Yeah, that's right. Okay. Well, you guys are sweet. And what an amazing thing we've been part of together with the office and everything. It's really exciting. And I love that you guys are doing this for the fans and revisiting all this. It was really fun watching the episode last night. All right. Well, great. We'll see you for dinner party, lady. All right. I'll see you then. Thanks, Melara. Bye, you guys. Angela, I think we should get into this episode.
Let's start talking about the client. Okay. Can we talk about Michael and his jeans? Yes. Oh my gosh. This cold open made me laugh so hard. I just think it's really funny that when Michael is dancing around in his jeans, there's this tiny spy shot of Angela Martin's head that's to the left of the potted plant while Michael is dancing on the end table. And she's just looking there snarky, but I'm so short. My head barely comes over the partition. And so there's the plant and then my head just for like a split second at 18 seconds. And then back again, when he's goofing off, I'm like judging him from the copier. So Angela Martin is just being placed in these little spaces in the background judging. Well, I remember that I had to have a big wardrobe fitting of quote,
unquote, casual clothes so that we could shoot these flashbacks to casual Fridays. But Angela, are you just wearing your regular gray office wear? I am never, I never participate in casual Friday. What's interesting to me is that this cold open implies that we have casual Fridays at the office. But so far, we've never shown a casual Friday or reference to casual Friday. And I believe we never do again, even though we very often have episodes set on a Friday. No, this is the one time I said, also, there's some real great PAM sass in this cold open because what do you do at the end? You just chunk his jeans under the chunk them? Yes, you just, you flip them over and you toss them. Have you been saying chunk your whole life? It's chuck.
You chuck them. Wait, no. Have you? Have you been saying chunk for your whole life? I think I said you chunk it at something. Chunk it? Sam, Sam, it's chuck, right? It's chuck. It's 100% chuck. Some people. Another wiffle. Oh my God. Do you chunk your wiffle ball? I chunk it. You chunk it. Chunk it real hard at someone. Oh my God, I've taken my glasses off because I'm crying. I'm crying, I'm loving so hard. I chunk it. You don't chunk it. Oh man. Oh Lord. Yeah, PAM chucks the jeans into the trash. Well, there is some PAM sass there. There is. Also, how long in my life have I been saying things wrong? And now I'm just learning about it all
in the podcast. I don't know. Oh God, okay. Well, that is life intimidating art right there. Okay, so after the scene with the jeans, the show opens with Michael and Jan having a meeting. They're talking about how they're hoping to secure a very big account. Lackawanna County, the whole county, they will buy their paper from Dunder Mifflin. This is when Michael tells Jan he has changed the meeting from the Radisson, which he describes as too snooty, to Chili's, which he says is the new golf course where business happens. Yes, I have that on a card. I thought it was so funny, the Radisson. Too snooty. Too snooty. Too snooty. Too stuffy. I have two note cards from this scene that I have to bring up. Oh, well then go. I mean,
at a minute 16 seconds, you guys, Jan has hot pink nail polish. She does? Yes. I think Angela Martin is probably judging her. I mean, you know, she judges her, but hot pink nail polish in the workplace, I'm just saying. And then a minute 31 seconds, Jim has a talking head and he says that if we get this big Lackawanna account, we might not have to downsize, but didn't we just downsize in the Halloween episode? Well, we let go of one person, but I think the bigger deal is that they're saying an entire branch might have to close. So it's either us or Stanford. Got it. It's going to have to close completely. Okay. So this would save us. I got it. This moves us into the scene in the kitchen where everyone is telling their worst first date stories. Oscar tells a story
about how he went on a date and he found out the woman had background checked him. The woman. Yes. I have this on a note card. I'm like, Oscar is telling this like kind of horrible date scenario where he went on a date with a woman. So did, did the writers not know that they were going to make Oscar gay yet? Or is Oscar kind of covering in front of his co-workers? Well, that backstory of being on a date with someone who'd done a background check on you, that was based on a real story of Paul Lieberstein's dating life. What? Yeah. He said he went on to date the woman for a while, but that on their first date, she revealed that she had done like some, a real deep dive on him to make sure that he was on the up and
up. I have a fan question. Both Sarah Clark and Kim asked who came up with Pam's worst first date story. Well, Pam's story of being left at a hockey game was not based on anyone's real story, but the writers went around the room and they just pitched worst first date stories. Where is the worst place that you could leave a date? That was their assignment one afternoon. That's a little insight into the writer's room. What it's like. They sit in there on a bunch of couches and they eat snacks. They eat a lot of snacks up there. They really do. Cause we would go steal their snacks. We would steal their snacks, but they also do sit at a table with computers as well. Well, they do, but sometimes when they pitch these ideas, it's really fun to go in there
because they'll say, okay, what is the worst place to leave a date? And then they just go around there and you just shout it out. It's like so fun in a writer's room because I feel like when they do that kind of stuff, it's almost like playing a game of Pictionary or something in your living room. So they said that they had a lot of alternates, but this was their favorite. They liked the idea. I wish we could know what their alternates were. I know. This is the one that ended up in the script, but I think it's perfect. First of all, that he took her to a minor league hockey game on their first date. Second, that he brought his brother. And then third, that they left her there. Yeah. And then that it was Roy. Yeah. It totally supports the
backstory you made up that he bought Seedoo's with the money you were going to plan your wedding with. Yeah. With his brother. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I loved it. I thought it was perfect. At three minutes, 35 seconds, in the background, there is a mail cart, like a rolly mail cart. Oh yeah, it's there a lot. No one ever pushes it. No one ever delivers from it. No, sometimes we've had people push that cart, I think. I feel like Oscar has done something with that cart. Really? I don't know, guys. We don't have a designated mail person though that like comes around with their mail. We don't have a mail room. We don't. I feel like Pam handles all the mail. Well, then she just pushes the cart to the back of the room. Well, I never pushed the cart,
but maybe anyone out there comment us, let us know. Yeah, who pushes the cart? At three minutes, 54 seconds, you can see three photos on my desk. Yes. Look, I have one of them. Oh, Janet, there's a photo of your sister and her husband taped to your desk. Yes, that's right. Yes. And my sister's husband's name is Dwight. Isn't that crazy? Now, the writers didn't know that. That was just all like by chance. Yes. Here's a little bit of interesting trivia. My father's name is Jim. My brother-in-law's name is Dwight. And my niece's name is Cece. Well, and they named the character after Cece. Yes. That the other two were already happening. Yeah. But that one was all you. My niece Cece was born about a week before we filmed
the episode where Pam and Jim have their baby. And I asked if we could name their baby Cece after my niece. I think that's so cute. All right, ladies, should we take a break? I think we should. I see you've paired down your note cards here. I'm pairing down my note cards. I've collected myself. I'm no longer laughing at you when you just simply look at me. Thank you. Thank you for admitting that all I'm doing is looking at you. I know, but the expression was really funny. Dwight, now you just did it again. You just implied that there's some way I'm looking at you. This is your thing. I'm going to take a sneaky photo of your face. Don't you dare. Lady, you do. I have to do the impression. Ready? This is my
impression. You be me. Hold on. Look down at your note, whatever you're doing. Okay. Ready? And those are my fast facts. Nothing? You have nothing? Angela, this is a podcast. You're supposed to talk. That's my impression. But did you see my face? Barely. Those are my fast facts. And those are my fast facts. Your turn. Okay. We are back. Michael and Jan are getting ready to leave to go to Chili's for their big meeting. And did you notice in the parking lot, Michael says, Chili's is just a couple blocks away. They should just drive together. However, the closest Chili's is actually about 30 minutes away in Wilkesbury at the Wyoming Valley Mall. Somebody did a little bit of a deep dove. I
remember this. I remember when we were shooting it that we discovered that there isn't really a Chili's in Scranton. You have to go outside to get there. And it wasn't a big deal when we did the dundies. But here, Michael does say it's only a couple blocks away, but it's not. And then he goes on to say, you don't know Scranton at all. It's like, well, maybe, maybe you don't know it. What was it like for all the people in Scranton to see this episode and be like, wait, what? Where's the Chili's? Well, they probably had the same moment when they saw a palm tree or two every once in a while. They'd be like, wait, what's a palm tree doing in there? I also want to say, I looked it up. There still isn't a Chili's in Scranton. Chili's missed opportunity here. You
guys want to go ahead and put a Chili's in Scranton already? Chili's, maybe you should call us, because Jenna has some business plan for you. We will cut the ribbon. Oh, we would cut the ribbon. We'll cut the ribbon. I've never done that. That'd be fun. I know. I've always wanted to do that, where you hold the giant scissors. Don't chunk them though. I won't chunk them, Angela. I will not chunk them at anyone. So they walk inside the Chili's to one of my all-time favorite scenes. Yes. I bet it's this. I'm putting up my note card. It is. Is it, is Gould dead? No Gould. When she says no Gould, when Steve's face as Michael, when he whips around and goes, no Gould, like it is, you see everything in him go electric. Yes. Is Gould dead? Do you want to talk about it?
大家想不想现在就去斯克兰顿开一家智利烧烤？智利烧烤，也许你们该给我们打个电话，因为珍妮为你们准备了一份商业计划书。我们会去剪彩。哦，我们会剪彩的。我们会剪彩的。我以前从没做过。那一定很有趣。我知道。我一直想做那种拿着巨型剪刀的事。不过别把它们剪断哦。我不会剪断它们的，安吉拉。我才不会对着任何人乱剪呢。然后他们走进智利烧烤，看到了我最喜欢的场景之一。是的。我敢打赌就是这个。我把记事本举起来了。就是这个。是不是，古尔德死了吗？没有古尔德。当她说没有古尔德时，当史蒂夫扮演迈克尔转过身去说“没有古尔德”时，就像，你能看到他体内的所有东西都通电了。是的。古尔德死了吗？你想谈谈吗？
Are you okay? We're in a meeting, Michael. Michael, we're in a meeting. And then he has to give that look to camera. Yeah. Oh my God. It's so good. Oh man, Steve is so good in that scene. Oh, we have the same thing written down now. What? I just peeked at your note card, the waitress Megan. You hold your paper up so I can't see it, but my note cards are right here in front of you. That's your business. Five minutes, 47 seconds. Megan, may we have an awesome blossom, please? I think this is a great detail. Now, I don't know if this was in the script. I don't know if Steve improvised that, but I love that Michael remembers the waitress by name. I absolutely believe that the character of Michael would remember every waiter or waitress by name.
你还好吗？我们在开会，迈克尔。迈克尔，我们在开会。然后他不得不冲着镜头做出那个表情。是的。噢天哪。太棒了。天哪，史蒂夫在那场戏里演得太棒了。哦，我们记下的东西一模一样。什么？我刚偷看了你的记事本，那个女服务员梅根。你把纸举起来挡住不让我看，但我的记事本就在你面前。那是你的事。5分47秒。梅根，请给我们来一份至尊洋葱花球，好吗？我觉得这是一个很棒的细节。现在，我不知道这在剧本里有没有。我不知道这是不是史蒂夫即兴发挥的，但我喜欢迈克尔能叫出服务员的名字。我绝对相信迈克尔这个角色会记得每一个男服务员或女服务员的名字。
I think that Michael, every flight attendant. Yes, I was going to say, I think Michael knows the name of every person he has to interact with. Yes. And it's his pleasure to get to know their name. And I love that he knows the waitresses, Megan. It is a great, great detail. Six minutes, 19 seconds. Michael calls Pam on the phone back at the office to get him to read her a bunch of jokes from these joke books in his office. I got a lot of questions about this. People wanting to know the punchline for that joke about the lighthouse that Pam starts. And Michael's like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. There is no punchline to the joke. It was not in the book. Those jokes, quote unquote, were scripted and they just wrote the beginning of the jokes. Oh, I love it. There
我觉得迈克尔，每一个空姐。是的，我正要说，我觉得迈克尔知道他必须与之交往的每一个人的名字。是的。而且他很乐意去了解他们的名字。我喜欢他知道女服务员叫梅根。这是一个非常非常棒的细节。6分19秒。迈克尔给办公室里的帕姆打电话，让她给他读办公室里这些笑话书上的一堆笑话。我收到了很多关于这个的问题。人们想知道帕姆开始讲的那个关于灯塔的笑话的妙语是什么。迈克尔却说，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。这个笑话没有妙语。书里没有。那些所谓的笑话是按剧本写的，他们只写了笑话的开头。哦，我太喜欢了。
were no endings. I bet the writers had a lot of fun with that. Just writing the first line of a joke that they know they have, they don't have to worry about the payoff. That would have been fun. Well, and I had the challenge of having to memorize the line, but look like I was reading from the book that I was not reading from. Oh yeah, that's tricky. It was a little tricky. After this, Pam finds threat level midnight, the script that Michael has written where he is an action star, Michael Skarn. And at seven minutes, 18 seconds, Jim finds drawings of the threat level midnight poster within the script. And we had a fan question from Becca Ramirez. She asked, who made the drawings in the script of threat level midnight? Do you know? I don't. Great question. Greg Daniels.
没有结尾。我敢打赌编剧们对此乐此不疲。只写一个他们知道不用担心笑果的笑话的第一行。那一定很有趣。好吧，我有背台词的挑战，但看起来像是在读我根本没在读的书。哦对，这很棘手。确实有点棘手。在此之后，帕姆发现了《最高机密》，那是迈克尔写的剧本，他在里面扮演一个动作明星，迈克尔·斯坎。在7分18秒时，吉姆在剧本里发现了《最高机密》海报的画作。我们有一个来自贝卡·拉米雷斯的粉丝提问。她问，《最高机密》剧本里的画是谁画的？你知道吗？我不知道。好问题。格雷格·丹尼尔斯。
Did he really? He made the drawings himself. Oh my gosh, I could see him sort of sitting on the side quickly drawing them. So he sketched them out. And then he gave them to, I guess it would be Phil Shea. Yeah. And Phil hired an artist. But this was the example, like Greg kind of sketched it out to say, here's my idea of what the poster, this is what the drawing should look like. And Greg said the artist came back and the drawings were so good that he thought, he thought maybe his kind of crappier drawing was more realistic. More realistic. Yeah. That Michael would do that. Yes. So he kept his own drawing in. I think it's just perfect. Okay. Well, two things. Number one, here's the actual joke that Michael tells. At the chilies. At the chilies. Here's the
真的是他吗？他自己画的画。天哪，我能想象他坐在旁边飞快地画画的样子。所以他是草草画出来的。然后他把画交给了，我猜应该是菲尔·谢伊。是的。然后菲尔雇了一个艺术家。但这只是个例子，格雷格大概是草草画了一下，说，这是我对海报的想法，画就应该是这样的。格雷格说，那个艺术家拿回来的画太好了，以至于他觉得，他觉得也许他自己那种比较烂的画更现实。更现实。是的。迈克尔会这么做。是的。所以他保留了自己的画。我觉得这简直完美。好吧，有两件事。第一，这是迈克尔讲的真实笑话。在智利烧烤店。在智利烧烤店。这是
actual joke. Well, I'm an astronaut. So I drive a Saturn. Second guy says, I'm a pimp. So I drive a cheap escort. Third guy says, I got you both beat. I'm a proctologist. So I drive a brown probe. Yeah. And that's the line that like makes Christian, the client just roll over laughing. How about it's seven minutes, 36 seconds. They're all eating this awesome blossom with no drinks, not even waters. Megan, where's their waters? Megan. I mean, those are kind of salty. You need your water. You do. Oh, I have a fan question. Okay. So a lot of people asked if this was the same chilies where we shot dundies. Yes. All right. I did some research. So we got a lot of conflicting information on this one when I went to research it. First of all, the internet says
真实的笑话。好吧，我是一名宇航员。所以我开土星。第二个家伙说，我是个拉皮条的。所以我开廉价护卫。第三个家伙说，你们俩我都比不上。我是个直肠科医生。所以我开棕色探测仪。是的。就是这句台词让客户克里斯蒂安笑得前俯后仰。7分36秒怎么样？他们都在吃这个至尊洋葱花球，却没有任何饮料，连水都没有。梅根，他们的水呢？梅根。我的意思是，那些东西有点咸。你需要水。确实。哦，我有一个粉丝问题。好吧。所以很多人问这跟我们拍《唐迪奖》的是不是同一家智利烧烤店。是的。好吧。我做了一些研究。当我着手研究时，我们得到了很多相互矛盾的信息。首先，互联网上说
it was not the same chilies, yet they have no citation for their information. That's right. So I asked Phil Shea, he said he thought it was the same one, but he said it was close to our set. But the original dundies one was not close to our set. Then I asked Greg, he said he couldn't remember, but he knows it was an empty black Angus. So I don't know. So I actually asked Tim this as well. I said, Tim, can you tell me a little bit about where you filmed? Cause we're trying to figure out if it was where we filmed the dundies. And he said, well, I can tell you this. It was like this really gross out of business restaurant in a kind of sketchy area. So maybe it was the same. I know. That makes me think it was the same. And he said it was gross
这不是同一家智利烧烤店，然而他们没有任何信息出处。没错。所以我问了菲尔·谢伊，他说他觉得是同一家，但他说离我们的片场很近。但原来拍《唐迪奖》的那家离我们的片场并不近。然后我问了格雷格，他说他记不清了，但他知道那是一家倒闭的空置安格斯牛排馆。所以我不知道。所以我实际上也问了蒂姆。我说，蒂姆，你能跟我讲讲你们是在哪里拍的吗？因为我们在试图弄清楚那是不是我们拍《唐迪奖》的地方。他说，好吧，我可以告诉你这个。那就像是一家非常恶心、倒闭的餐厅，在一个有点可疑的区域。所以也许是同一家。我知道。这让我觉得就是同一家。他说那里很恶心
because no one had been in that building in so long. There were like little nooks and crannies of it that were kind of dusty and corrody. As I was watching it, I couldn't tell if it was different. They did an excellent job of making it look like it was the same place. Yeah, I couldn't tell either, but Tim's description of it kind of brought me back. Eight minutes, 34 seconds, Michael's tie with the little mouth on it. Yes. That he uses to eat the awesome blossom. That was scripted that he would do that. And the wardrobe designer actually had to make that tie that is a custom made tie. She made seven different mouth options that she showed to Greg and he had to pick the mouth that would go on the tie.
因为那栋楼已经很久没人进去了。里面有一些犄角旮旯，有点满是灰尘和腐蚀。我一边看一边分不清是不是不同的地方。他们把这里布置得就像同一个地方一样，做得太棒了。对啊，我也分不清，但蒂姆的描述又把我拉回了那个地方。8分34秒，迈克尔系着带有小嘴巴图案的领带。是的。他用那个来吃至尊洋葱花球。剧本里写了他是会这么做的。服装设计实际上不得不制作那条定制领带。她制作了七种不同的嘴巴选项展示给格雷格，他必须挑选贴在领带上的嘴巴。
Oh my gosh. This is when I'm like, our jobs are crazy. That is a crazy thing. Hey, how was your day? Well, I had to make ties with mouths on them, like a bunch of different mouths. I made seven different mouths and then my boss picked one. Okay. Can we get to one of my favorite scenes, which is nine minutes, seven seconds, the baby back ribs. Yes. All right. I was so excited to talk to Tim about this. Now, a lot of you guys wrote in and said, was that improvised? Was it scripted? And here's what Tim said. Tim said the beginning of that song when Michael starts off singing was in the script and in the script that he was supposed
天哪。每当这个时候我就觉得，我们的工作太疯狂了。那真是一件疯狂的事。嘿，你今天过得怎么样？嗯，我得做带有嘴巴的领带，就像一堆不同的嘴巴。我做了七种不同的嘴巴，然后我老板挑了一个。好吧。我们能聊聊我最喜欢的场景之一吗，就是9分07秒的宝贝嫩排。是的。好吧。我很高兴能和蒂姆聊聊这个。现在，你们很多人写信来问，那是即兴发挥的吗？还是剧本里写的？蒂姆是这么说的。蒂姆说那首歌的开头，当迈克尔开始唱的时候是剧本里有的，并且在剧本里他应该
to join in at the end. Okay. Baby back ribs, right? At the end. And he said when they started filming it, Steve started to sing and it just kind of wasn't working when Tim joined in. So Tim started doing the other part, just kind of improvised that I want my baby back, baby back, baby back. And then it was like lightning bolt. Off to the races. We've got it. And he said one of his favorite moments, it's in the bloopers and I went and watched it is he goes to do his, I want my baby back back. And Steve just improvises, no, you come in later and he's like, Oh yeah, right. Like, and it's so funny. It's a great little moment in the bloopers. I watched those deleted scenes as well. So good.
在最后加入。好吧，宝贝嫩排，对吧？在最后。他说当他们开始拍摄时，史蒂夫开始唱，而当蒂姆加入时感觉有点不对劲。所以蒂姆开始唱另一部分，有点即兴发挥的意思：我想要我的宝贝排，宝贝排，宝贝排。然后就像一道闪电。大功告成。我们拍到了。他说他最喜欢的时刻之一，在NG花絮里，我去看了，就是他正准备唱：我想要我的宝贝排排，而史蒂夫直接即兴发挥说：不，你晚点再进来，然后他说：哦，对，没错。就像这样，太搞笑了。那是NG花絮里一个很棒的小片段。我也看了那些删减片段。太棒了。
So good. And Malora is right. Malora could not hold it together. I mean, can you blame her? No, they were so funny. And they really wanted to hold that three shot. They really wanted her to be the anchor of the scene. So they couldn't carve it up. They couldn't have all these singles or anything. So anytime she laughed, they had to start again. They did. You can also tell that those guys are having so much fun singing together. They're having a blast. The week after this scene, Steve was going to shoot to host Saturday Night Live. And so when I was there that day, I remember Tim giving him like some little, yeah, all the insider intro on what it would be like. Well, I actually said to Tim,
太棒了。而且玛洛拉说得对。玛洛拉根本憋不住。我的意思是，你能怪她吗？不，他们太搞笑了。他们真的很想把那个三人镜头拍下来。他们真的很想让她成为这场戏的主心骨。所以他们不能把它剪碎。他们不能用所有这些单人镜头什么的。所以只要她一笑，他们就得重来。确实如此。你也能看出那几个人一起唱歌玩得太开心了。他们玩得嗨极了。这场戏拍完的一周后，史蒂夫就要去主持《周六夜现场》了。所以当我那天在那儿的时候，我记得蒂姆给他提供了一些内幕消息，告诉他那会是什么样。好吧，我实际上对蒂姆说，
I was like, Tim, you and Steve had such great chemistry. How like, how long have you known each other? And he said, we've actually known each other a really, really long time. So they met a long, long time ago before any of them were famous when they were really young. They were all at Second City in Chicago. And they also did Improv Olympic. And then Tim was cast on SNL with Nancy Carell and Dave Kekner. Oh my gosh. Right. But he said, honestly, he said when they became really, really tight and got to know each other is the summer when he had off from Saturday Night Live, all of those guys went and did a Second City tour in DC. And they were there for the summer. And he said, that was so much fun. He said they would do their show. And then after the show,
我说，蒂姆，你和史蒂夫有这么好的默契。你们，你们认识多久了？他说，我们其实认识非常非常久了。所以他们在他们任何一个人成名之前，在他们还很年轻的时候，就在很久很久以前认识了。他们都在芝加哥的第二城剧团。他们还参加了即兴奥林匹克。然后蒂姆和南茜·卡瑞尔以及戴夫·科克纳一起被选入了《周六夜现场》。天哪。没错。但他说，老实说，他们变得非常非常铁、真正了解彼此，是在他从《周六夜现场》放假的那年夏天，所有那些人去华盛顿特区进行了一次第二城剧团巡演。他们在那里度过了那个夏天。他说，那太有趣了。他说他们会表演他们的演出，然后演出结束后，
they would all stay and do an improv set. And he said it's some of the best improv he's ever been a part of. Could you imagine if you could go back in time and buy a ticket to that show? I would have loved it. There are people who got to see that. Yeah. And Tim said, I was like, who is in the cast? And he said it was Steve and Nancy, John Glazer, Adam McKay, Theresa Mulligan, who I know, who is hilarious. And they just had the best time. Well, some of the most fun we ever had Angela off camera on our show was when we would get to hang out with the cast of Saturday Night Live. Because remember, they're an NBC show, we're an NBC show. So we would often have to do press with them. We would go to New York, they would fly the
他们都会留下来做一组即兴表演。他说这是他经历过的最好的即兴表演之一。你能想象如果你能回到过去买一张那场演出门票吗？我一定会爱死。确实有人看到了。是的。蒂姆说，我当时问，演员阵容里都有谁？他说有史蒂夫和南茜、约翰·格雷泽、亚当·麦凯、特蕾莎·穆利根，我认识她，她超级搞笑。他们度过了最美好的时光。好吧，安吉拉，我们在片场镜头外度过的最有趣的时光之一，就是有机会和《周六夜现场》的演员们一起玩。因为记住，他们是一个NBC节目，我们也是一个NBC节目。所以我们经常不得不和他们一起做宣传。我们会去纽约，他们会用飞机把《办公室》的演员接到纽约。我们会花整整一天时间开记者招待会。然后在晚上，他们会为NBC节目的所有演员举办一个小派对。那将是《办公室》的演员和《周六夜现场》的演员。我们会笑得前俯后仰。笑得前俯后仰。还有舞会。那些是我最美好的回忆。我甚至记得当时站在那儿掐自己，心想：记住这个，记住这一切。是的。我记得我记得的事情之一就是你和我去看《周六夜现场》。我们到了那里，然后我们有点和大家聚在一起，你知道的，在他们准备之前。所以我们只是快速打了个招呼。我们走向我们的座位。然后结束后我们又回到了
cast of The Office to New York. And we would spend an entire day doing press conferences. And then in the evenings, they would throw a little party for all of the actors on the NBC shows. And it would be the cast of The Office and the cast of Saturday Night Live. And we would just crack up. Crack up. And have dance parties. Those are some of my most fun memories. And I even remember being there and pinching myself and thinking, remember this, remember all of this. Yes. I remember one of the things I remember is that you and I going to watch Saturday Night Live. And we got there and we were sort of hanging out with everyone, you know, before they're kind of getting ready. So we just said, hi quickly. We went to our seats. And then afterwards we went back in
他们的化妆间，又待了大约半个小时。然后我们去了那个每个人、每场录制结束后都有的类似会后派对的地方。那真的很酷。但接着克里斯·帕内尔说：伙计们，你们想去会后派对吗？会后派对之后的派对。我当时想：等等，这难道不是会后派对吗？他说：不，不，不，是会后派对之后的派对。然后我们就去了会后派对之后的派对。那是在一家酒吧里，詹娜，看起来像个森林。里面有各种各样的树。我记得。你和我，我想我当时大概穿了一件牛仔裙。我在Gap买的。大家穿得都太酷了。我转向你，说道：现在已经是凌晨三点钟了。哦，我想当我们终于决定收工时，太阳都快升起来了。
their dressing rooms and hung out like another half hour. Then we went to this like after party that they have after everyone, every taping. That was really cool. But then Chris Parnell was like, guys, do you want to go to the after party? The after after party. And I was like, wait, isn't this the after party? And he goes, no, no, no, the after after party. And then we went to the after after party. And it was like in this bar, Jenna, that looked like a forest. It had all these trees. I remember. And you and I like, I think I just had on like a denim dress. I got it the gap. And like everyone was dressed so cool looking. And I turned to you and I was like, it is three in the morning. Oh, I think the sun was coming up when we finally called it a night.
我记得走到克里斯·帕内尔面前说：所以，我想我们结束了。他说：好吧，伙计们，他们还在那儿。太疯狂了。我们走了，而他们还留在那里。那些是我最美好的回忆。我很高兴我们做了那些事，因为我们其实是那种通常不会在外面待到很晚的人。不，我们不会。但我们豁出去了。而且，在《办公室》的全盛时期，有两组演员是我们经常聚在一起的，我想说是这样的。其中之一是《尼尔森的》……噢不，是《周六夜现场》，另一个是《广告狂人》。是的。《广告狂人》那个节目和我们是同期播出的。我经常和《广告狂人》的演员们一起玩。因为同样的原因，我们得去参加那些新闻发布会。所有节目的明星都会在他们各自的会议室里
I remember going up to Chris Parnell and being like, so I think we're done. He's like, all right, guys, they were still there. Crazy. We left and they were still there. Those are some of my favorite memories. And I'm so glad we did that stuff because we are kind of the people who don't normally stay out late. No, we don't. But we went for it. And I was, there were two casts that we hung out with a ton in our heyday of the office, I would say. And one of those was SNL and the other was Mad Men. Yes. Mad Men, that show was coming up at the same time that we were. And I would hang out with the cast of Mad Men a lot. Because the same thing, we would have to go to these press junkets. And the stars of all the shows would be in their various conference rooms
向媒体发言，但随后他们会为我们所有人准备某种大型自助午餐。我会和所有《广告狂人》的人闲聊。我最终经常交谈的另一组演员，我真的觉得他们非常棒，那就是《废柴联盟》。哦，没错。那个节目的每个人都太酷太好玩了。我喜欢，当我们和他们搭档做宣传的时候。好吧，把我们带回这一集，你知道他们吃排骨的那场戏吗？是的。好吧。我发现了一个非常有趣的小细节。我听了DVD评论音轨。其实那是保罗和格雷格发出的吮吸声。哦，不。他们在剪辑室里录下了吮吸声，叠加在那场戏的顶端，只是为了让它变得更加恶心，
speaking to the press, but then they'd have some like big buffet lunch for all of us. And I would chit chat with all the Mad Men people. The other cast that I ended up talking to quite a bit, who I really thought were fantastic, was Community. Oh, yes. That's right. Everyone on that show was just so cool and fun. And I loved getting, when we got partnered with them, you know, to do press. Well, bringing us back to the episode, you know that scene where they're eating the ribs? Yeah. Okay. I found out a really interesting little tidbit. I listened to the DVD commentary. That's actually Paul and Greg making the slurping sounds. Oh, no. They recorded slurping sounds in the editing room to lay on top of that scene to just make it even grosser
好配合玛洛拉的反应。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。这让我更加喜爱我们的节目，因为我觉得我们就像是一个微不足道的小引擎，这个能办到的小团队就像：我们需要两个人来发出吮吸声。哦，这种事经常发生。是的，经常发生。不过，你还有一些关于蒂姆的事情要说。你想说什么？好吧，我只是问他，你知道的，他是否听说过《办公室》以及他是如何得到这份工作的。他说他是BBC版本的超级粉丝。并且他说当他接到关于这个节目的电话时，它还不是个热门剧集，对吧？那还是早期。有点像，这个节目到底是讲什么的？他说在核心喜剧圈里，人们会觉得这个节目
for Malora's reaction. That is so funny. That is so funny. And just makes me like love our show because I felt like we were just like this little, this little engine that could, this little team of like, we need two people to make slurping sounds. Oh, that happened all the time. Yeah, all the time. You have some more stuff about Tim, though. What do you want to say? Well, I just asked him, you know, if he, you know, had heard of the office and how he came to get the job. And he said that he was a humongous fan of the BBC version. And he said that when he got the call about the show that it was not a hit, right? It was kind of early on. It was sort of, sort of like, what is the show about? And like, he said in like inner comedy circles, people were like, the show
真的很好笑。所以他知道它很好笑，但感觉上，世界还没有真正了解这部节目。而且他当时挺忙的。他当时想：我不知道，伙计们，我不知道我能不能演。所以他最初拒绝了。哦，他拒绝了。是的。然后他们又打电话来，蒂姆说他的戏剧经纪人助理说：蒂姆，这个节目太搞笑了。然后他说：好吧，好吧，好吧，我演。我演。并且他说他很高兴自己演了。当然，他和史蒂夫度过了最美好的时光，蒂姆现在正在ABC的一个名叫《学园笑传》的节目里演出。每周三晚上8点30分播出。所以去看看吧。谢谢你，蒂姆。所以现在，安吉拉，我觉得我们应该回到办公室，稍微聊聊《最高机密》。哦，是的。办公室里的每个人
is really funny. So he knew it was funny, but it was like, the world didn't really know about this show yet. And he was kind of busy. And he was like, I don't know, guys, I don't know that I can do it. And, and so he initially said no. Oh, he turned it down. Yes. And then they called back and Tim said his theatrical manager's assistant was like, Tim, this show is so hilarious. And he was like, All right, all right, all right, I'll do it. I'll do it. And he said he's so glad he did. Of course, he had the best time with Steve and Tim is right now on a show on ABC called schooled. It's on Wednesday at 8 30 p.m. So check it out. Thanks, Tim. So now Angela, I think we should go back into the office and talk a little bit about threat level midnight. Oh, yes. Everyone in the office
走进会议室，他们分配角色并开始阅读《最高机密》。我认为这是桌上剧本围读是什么样的一个很好的例子。这就是我们在《办公室》里每周都会做的事情。周二或周三的午餐时间，我们都会走进这间会议室，他们会分发下一周的剧本，然后我们会大声朗读出来。是的。通常情况下，导演就是旁白，他们会读所有的舞台指示。而在《最高机密》中，你们所有人一起朗读时，吉姆就是旁白。他让奥斯卡饰演黄金脸。但当《最高机密》真正拍出来时，吉姆才是黄金脸。是的。没错。这里有个小包袱。这里我最喜欢的事情之一就是德维，迈克尔那个笨手笨脚的助手
goes into the conference room, they divide up the parts and they start reading threat level midnight. I think this is a great example of what a table read is like. This is what we would do every week on the office. Tuesdays or Wednesdays at lunch, we would all go into this conference room, they would hand out the next week's script, and we would read it out loud. Yeah. And usually, the director was the narrator, they would read all the stage direction. And on threat level midnight, Jim is the narrator when you guys all read it. And he casts Oscar as golden face. But when threat level midnight is actually made, Jim is golden face. Yes. Yes, that's right. A little catch there. One of my favorite things in this is DwiGT, the fact that Michael's bumbling assistant
显然以前叫德怀特。所以帕姆给出的那个解释了拼写错误以及所有这些的独白镜头，我们第一次拍摄这一集时，那个解释并不存在。所以那是后来补拍的。我其实挺喜欢那个独白镜头的，因为它帮我理清了头绪，因为塞缪尔·L·陈实际上就是德维。没错。好吧，这是我们在剧本围读的《最高机密》中看到的演员阵容。现在，一旦它成为一部真正的电影，它就变得更加饱满，事情也发生了变化，我们在第七季中看到了这一点。菲利斯是凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯。德怀特是迈克尔·斯坎。奥斯卡是黄金脸。瑞恩是塞缪尔·L·陈。这就是我们看到的仅有的几个被选中的演员。其他人都在周围坐着，但只有这些是被点到名字的。
clearly used to be named Dwight. So that talking head that Pam gives where she explains the typo and all of that, the first time we shot this episode, that explanation did not exist. And so that was a reshoot. I actually liked that talking head because it helped it make sense for me because Samuel L. Chang was actually DwiGT. That's right. Well, here's the cast that we see in threat level midnight at the table read. Now, it's more fleshed out and things have changed once it's an actual movie, and we see that in season seven. Phyllis is Catherine Zeta-Jones. Dwight is Michael Skarn. Oscar is golden face. Ryan is Samuel L. Chang. And that's the only people that are cast in what we see. Everyone else is sort of sitting around, but those are the ones
好吧，我这里有一个很大的粉丝问题。很多人问《最高机密》是不是一个完整写好的剧本。他们确实写了相当多的内容，以便我们能有东西可拍，但正如你在剧集中看到的，这是一个未完成的剧本。所以它并不是一个完全写好的剧本。他们还想知道我们是照着剧本读的还是即兴发挥的。接下来，我本来想说我们是照着剧本读的，但我发现了一个对布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳的采访，他说那是我们即兴发挥的，BJ也证实了这一点，我们坐在那里大约五到十分钟，然后我们只是随便抛出任何东西，这在我看来几乎是不可能的，但剧组里有两个人说情况就是这样的。我记得不一样。
that are called out. Well, I had a big fan question here. A lot of people asked if threat level midnight was a fully written script. They did write quite a bit so that we would have something to work with, but as you see in the show, it's an unfinished script. So it was not a fully written script. They also wanted to know if we read from the script or if it was improvised. Next, I was going to say that I thought we read from the script, but I found an interview with Brian Baumgartner where he said we improvised it and BJ backed that up, that we were sitting around for about five to 10 minutes and we were just throwing out anything at all, which seems almost impossible to me, but there's two people in the cast who say that's how it was. I remember it
甚至菲利斯，当她说：我有两件事要说。第一件事是，我爱你。不，不，不。所以我应该说，其中一些是按剧本演的，但我们确实也即兴发挥了一些。好吧。所以两者都有。而且我们在拍摄时经常发生这种情况。他们会一直让摄像机转着，然后我们就会抛出一些东西，有些即兴发挥就保留了下来。我太喜欢了。但你绝对能看出场景的开头是按剧本写的，把你引入其中。是的，确实如此。回到智利烧烤店，伙计们，让我们来喝点含酒精饮料，做个时间码统计。哦天哪。所以在7分59秒时，珍点了一杯伏黛加汤力水。我们从没看到这杯伏黛加汤力水。哦，没错。是的。在8分35秒时，
differently. Even Phyllis, when she said, I have two things to say. First thing is, I love you. No, no, no. So I should say some of it was scripted, but we did also improvise some. Okay. So it was both. And that happened a lot when we were shooting. They would leave the cameras rolling and then we would throw stuff out there and some of the improvisations stayed in. I love that. But you could definitely tell the beginning of the scene was scripted, getting you into it. Yes, that's true. Back at Chili's, guys, let's have a little bit of an adult beverage timecode count. Oh dear. So at seven minutes 59 seconds, Jan orders a vodka tonic. We never see this vodka tonic. Oh, that's right. Yeah. At eight minutes 35 seconds,
他们都点了玛格丽特酒。所以珍是在喝第二杯吗？在13分44秒时，迈克尔和克里斯蒂安在喝啤酒。珍看起来在喝加青柠的水。我看不出来。那是在一个高杯子里。也许这终于算是她的伏黛加汤力水了。我不知道。对于像我这样喜欢背景细节的你们来说，这就是我们的含酒精饮料统计。安吉拉，我已经准备好带大家去约会了。去屋顶。去屋顶。帕姆和吉姆的屋顶约会。我有太多问题了。我有太多的技术性问题，还有一些，你知道的，办公室粉丝的问题。你想知道什么？你们是怎么爬上那个屋顶的？好吧。所以你在剧集里看到的那个梯子确实通往屋顶。
they all have margaritas. So is Jan on her second drink? At 13 minutes 44 seconds, Michael and Christian are having beers. Jan looks like she's having a water with lime. I can't tell. It's in a tall glass. Maybe that's finally her vodka tonic. I don't know. That's our adult beverage count for those of you who love the background stuff like me. Angela, I'm ready to take us on a date. To the roof. To the roof. Pam and Jim's roof date. I have so many questions. I have so many technical questions and I have some just, you know, fan of the office questions. What do you want to know? How did you get up on that roof? Okay. So the ladder that you see in the episode really leads up to the roof.
你们真的爬那个看起来像防火梯的小梯子了吗？我和约翰没有。但那是剧组工作人员上去的方式。好吧。我和约翰，我猜出于安全原因和保险原因，我们穿上了安全带。好吧。然后他们把我们吊到屋顶上。就像某种叉车一样的东西吗？是的。放在某种奇怪的平台式叉车里，这看起来比允许我使用梯子更吓人、更危险。而且我们是在邓德米夫林的真实屋顶上拍摄的。我宁愿爬梯子。我也是。我要求爬梯子，但我们是坐平台叉车上下。好吧。我有一个关于屋顶的粉丝问题。好吧。詹姆斯·K问，屋顶上冷吗？
Do you really climb that little fire escape looking ladder? John and I did not. But that is how the crew got up there. Okay. John and I, for I guess, safety reasons and insurance reasons, we got into a harness. Okay. And then they lifted us up to the roof. Like in a forklift kind of thing? Yeah. In some sort of weird platformy forklift, which seemed scarier and more dangerous than if I'd just been allowed to use the ladder. And we shot on the actual roof of Dunder Mifflin. I would rather climb the ladder. Same. I asked to climb the ladder, but we went up and down on the platform forklift. Okay. I have a fan question about the roof. Okay. James K asked, was it cold on the roof?
看起来很冷。并不冷。不冷吗？安吉拉，拍摄这场戏是我对这部剧有史以来最美好的回忆之一，因为屋顶上只有我、约翰、格雷格·丹尼尔斯、保罗·利伯斯坦、我们的第一副导演以及我们的摄像师和摄影指导兰德尔·埃因霍恩。那里很暖和。那是一个温暖的夏日傍晚，但却是一个美丽的夏夜。温暖的微风。那是，我无法解释，但我们这小群人在屋顶上，当我在那儿的时候，我突然意识到：我在拍电视剧。我在过我的梦想生活。这太棒了，对吧？我确信感觉真的很神奇，就像一个神奇的时刻，完全神奇。我们当时已经作为一个团队真正磨合好了。我们真的齐心协力地融入其中。我们都爱
It looked cold. It wasn't. It wasn't? Angela, shooting the scene is one of my fondest memories of all time from the show because the only people on the roof were me, John, Greg Daniels, Paul Lieberstein, our first AD and our camera operator and DP, Randall Einhorn. It was warm. It was a warm summer evening, but like a beautiful summer night. Warm breeze. It was, I can't explain it, but this little group of us up on the roof, it hit me while I was up there. I'm on a TV show. I'm living my dream. This is amazing, right? I'm sure it felt really magical, just like a magical moment, completely magical. We had really gelled as a group at this point. We were really in it all together. We all loved
这个节目爱得深沉。我们太喜欢工作了。那真的是非常非常特别，而且烤奶酪三明治吃起来太美味了。太棒了。我还有另一个粉丝问题。唐娜问，有没有人被看起来有点危险的烟花弄伤？我最近见到了布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳，我问了他关于烟花的事。他说，詹娜，那太疯狂了。这些烟花没有特技协调员。他说，因为他们必须从很远的地方拍摄我们的镜头，所以他们真的把他们两个留在了这个停车场场地的中央，看起来很孤单，看起来非常干燥。是的。好吧，你知道的，在洛杉矶放烟花是违法的。天哪。他们甚至很难为这场戏弄到烟花。我们在违法吗？
the show so much. We loved being at work so much. It was just really, really special, and the grilled cheese sandwiches tasted so good. It was great. I have another fan question. Donna asked, was anyone hurt by the fireworks that looked kind of dangerous? I saw Brian Baumgartner recently, and I asked him about the fireworks. He said, Jenna, it was insane. There was no stunt coordinator for these fireworks. He said, because they had to get the shot of us from so far away, they really left the two of them out in the middle of this parking lot field, which looked alone, looked very dry. Yeah. Well, you know, fireworks are illegal in LA. Oh my gosh. They had a hard time even getting fireworks for this scene. We were breaking the law?
我不确定。我知道BJ曾在某篇文章中说过，关于烟花能有多大有一条规定。他们不被允许往空中发射任何东西，因为洛杉矶非常干燥。没错。我想我确实知道这一点。所以你可以玩那种在地面上的东西，但仅此而已。是的。所以它们就像地面上的那种仙女棒。是的。布赖恩说他们什么也听不见。他们几乎听不到“开始”或“停”。他们只是在那儿摆弄这些烟花，但在某个时刻，他听到有人大喊：从它们上面跳过去。踢它们。那可能是格雷格。那可能是格雷格在尖叫。但布赖恩说他们感觉非常真实，我想这也是那天晚上的经历之所以如此神奇的一部分原因，因为真的就像我们在看着那些家伙
I'm not sure. I know BJ said once in an article that there was a rule about how big the fireworks could be. They weren't allowed to shoot anything up in the air because LA is very dry. That's right. I think I do know that. So you can do the thing that's on the ground, but that's it. Yes. So they were like the sparkler thing on the ground. Yes. And Brian said that they couldn't hear anything. They could barely hear action or cut. They just were out there playing these fireworks, but at a certain point, he heard someone shout, hop over them. Kick them. It was probably Greg. It was probably Greg screaming. But Brian said they felt very real, and I think that was part of it about what made that night so magical was that it was really like we were watching those guys
用烟花胡闹，因为你们确实在胡闹。是的。是的。在这之后，当我们从屋顶下来时，你知道的，吉姆和帕姆，他们离开办公室，戴着耳机在听音乐。哦，在14分34秒。我有一个记事本上写着“老科技警报”。什么？因为那是iPod。是的。那是iPod。而且你们俩戴着那种小耳机，一人分到一个小耳塞。太可爱了。好吧，马特·赫尔特问，当你和约翰拍摄摇摆跳舞的场景时，你们在听什么，如果有的话？好吧，这也是我的问题之一，马特。那是什么？好吧，你在剧集里听到的那首歌是特拉维斯乐队的《Sing》。但我和约翰当时其实在听一首国际乐队（Interpol）的歌。哪首歌？
goof around with fireworks because they were because you were. Yes. Yes. And after this, when we come down from the roof, you know, Jim and Pam, they leave the office and they're listening on the headphones. Oh, at 14 minutes, 34 seconds. I have a note card that says old tech alert. What? Because it's an iPod. Yes. It's an iPod. And you guys have like the little headphones where you each take a little ear. It's so cute. Well, Matt Hurt asked, what if anything were you and John listening to when you shot the swaying dancing scene? Okay, that's one of my questions too, Matt. So what was it? Okay, the song you hear in the episode is a song called Sing by Travis. But John and I were actually listening to an Interpol song. Which song?
我不记得了。但你知道那是国际乐队的歌。是的。我记得那个。而且我想那是约翰真正的iPod，是他建议听那首歌，让我们听那首歌的。吉姆和帕姆的粉丝会爱死这个的。是的。而且那也很可爱。同样的温暖夏日傍晚。太棒了。所以我们和玛洛拉聊了聊接下来的场景，也就是迈克尔和珍在停车场。那是15分21秒。那是大热吻。是的，大热吻。好吧。所以我觉得这里有一个极其精彩的时刻。我不知道那是写在剧本里的还是史蒂夫即兴发挥的，它恰恰展现了迈克尔和珍刚刚接吻并且她说“我们离开这里吧”之后，迈克尔是多么欣喜若狂、飘飘然。他太飘飘然了。我把这场戏记了下来，因为我觉得它太可爱了。
I don't remember. But you know it was Interpol. Yes. I remember that. And I think that was John's actual iPod and that he suggested that song, that we listen to the song. Jam fans are going to love that. Yeah. And that was also lovely. Same warm summer evening. It was awesome. So we talked to Melora a little bit about the next scene, which is Michael and Jan in the parking lot. That's at 15 minutes, 21 seconds. It is the big smooch. Yes, the big smooch. All right. So I feel like there's just this brilliant moment. And I don't know if it was written or if Steve improvised this that just shows how over the moon giddy Michael is that him and Jan just kissed and that she said, let's get out of here. He's so giddy. And I wrote down the scene because I thought it was so adorable.
是在15分21秒。珍说，珍突然之间，可以说是有了镜头意识，对吧？是的。她在找摄像机。这被拍进录像带里了吗？她没有找到摄像机，但她在纳闷。没错。所以她说：我们走吧。迈克尔说：什么？她说：我们走吧。他说：我们要去哪儿？哦，好吧。没关系。去搞怪。（译者注：原文go-go指go-go舞厅，此处谐音playful译为搞怪）去搞怪。去搞怪。我觉得这太可爱了。他简直太兴奋了。我觉得这太可爱了。好吧。现在是第二天早晨了。邓德米夫林的摄制组进入办公室。他们有钥匙吗？你注意到了吗？德怀特正睡在沙发上。也许门根本没锁。我知道。也许他那天晚上根本没锁门。为什么德怀特穿着蓝色
It's at 15 minutes, 21 seconds. Jan says, Jan is sort of like all of a sudden camera aware, right? Yeah. She's looking for the camera. Is this getting caught on tape? She doesn't find the camera, but she wonders. Right. And so she says, let's go. And Michael goes, what? And she goes, let's go. And he says, where are we going? Oh, okay. Doesn't matter. Going to the go-go. Going to the go-go. Going to the go-go. I thought that was so cute. He's just so excited. I thought it was adorable. All right. So it's the next morning now. The Dunder Mifflin film crew enters the office. Do they have a key? Do you notice that? Dwight is sleeping on the couch. Maybe it's not even locked. I know. Maybe he never locked the door that night. Why is Dwight in blue
内裤和背心，盖着一张像锡箔纸一样的东西，就像联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）的防灾毛毯一样？好吧，我来告诉你，关于他该穿什么内裤，曾开过一个非常大的会议。当然会有啦。是的。会是平角裤吗？会是三角裤吗？什么颜色的？这就是他们决定的。当然关于德怀特的内裤会有一场盛大的会议。当然。是的。我知道。他们决定穿那种蓝色的、蓝色的、有点像三角内裤的。是的。它们，我猜，非常松垮。非常肥大。哦，你知道的，雷恩可喜欢了。他喜欢每一秒。那他跑向窗户的场景呢？安吉拉看到了珍。没错。所以显然摄像组抓包了珍，对吧？是的。她被抓了个现行。但还有两个邓德米夫林员工现在也知道了。安吉拉，她一大早就到达了
underwear and his tank top under like a foil, like a FEMA foil blanket? Well, I'll tell you, there was a very big meeting about what underwear he would wear. Of course there was. Yes. Would it be boxers? Would it be briefs? What color? This is what they decided. Of course there's a huge meeting about Dwight's underwear. Of course. Yeah. I know. And they decided on those blue, blue, kind of like tidy whiteies. Yeah. They're, I guess, very slouchy. Very baggy. Oh, you know, Rain loved that. He loved every second. What about the scene where he runs to the window? Angela sees Jan. That's right. So obviously the camera crew busts Jan, right? Yeah. She's so busted. But there are two Dunder Mifflin employees who also now know. Angela, who's arrived early in
停车场，还有德怀特，他正从窗户往下窥视。是的。然后珍看到了德怀特。我假设她开车经过时看到了安吉拉。但我喜欢德怀特和安吉拉。哦，我觉得她绝对注意到你了。哦，是的。我也这么觉得。但我喜欢德怀特和安吉拉，他们后来发展出了秘密恋情，却把珍抓了个正着。我喜欢在停车场的是安吉拉，因为我觉得在你经历“羞耻散步”时，你最不想看到的人就是安吉拉。正是如此。好吧。所以迈克尔带着他美味的秘密来到办公室。他乐不可支。我觉得玛洛拉把这一点描述得太好了。他是那么甜蜜、无辜和快乐，因为他……他太兴奋了。他演得太好了。他真的，他真的就像是，我不会谈论这个的，
the parking lot, and Dwight, who's peeping down from the window. Yeah. And Jan sees Dwight. I'm assuming she sees Angela as she drives by. But I love that Dwight and Angela. Oh, I think she totally clocks you. Oh, yeah. I do too. But I love that Dwight and Angela, who go on to have their secret relationship, totally busts Jan. I love that it's Angela in the parking lot because I feel like the very last person who you want to see during your walk of shame is Angela. Exactly. All right. So Michael arrives into the office with his delicious secret. He's so giddy. I felt like Melora described that so well. How sweet and innocent and happy he is that he... He's so excited. He's so good. He really, he really is like, I'm not going to talk about it,
对吧？不，我不会谈论这事的。绅士不谈论私密之事，我也不谈。哈哈哈。你知道的，然后紧接着我们知道的是，他说：我们必须披露，我们必须写一封信。是的，确实如此。关于我们的关系。他只是，噢天哪。在那段独白里，我喜欢那里的镜头运镜。那是对迈克尔脸部非常非常缓慢的推镜头。你能感觉到镜头给迈克尔施加了所有的压力，逼他说出真相。他坚持了多久？他坚持了大约14秒。秒。秒。他说：好吧，好吧。我们去了，我们去了……去我们的酒店。是的，我们亲热了一会儿。我抱着她，她跟我讲了她的离婚。天哪。那通和珍的电话，他躲到桌子底下，那是格雷格导演的。格雷格告诉
right? No, I'm not going to speak about it. Gentlemen, don't kiss and tell, and neither do I. Ha, ha, ha. You know, and then the next thing we know, he's like, we'll have to disclose, we'll have to write a letter. Yeah, that's so true. About our relationship. He just, oh man. In that talking head, I love the camera work in that. It's a very, very slow push in on Michael's face. And you can just feel the camera putting all this pressure on Michael to tell the truth. How long does he last? He lasts like 14 seconds. Seconds. Seconds. He's like, all right, fine. We went, we went back and we... To our hotel. Yeah, we made out for a little bit. I held her and she talked to me about her divorce. Oh my gosh. That phone call with Jan, where he goes under the desk, Greg directed that. Greg told
史蒂夫，你为什么不躲到桌子底下接这个电话，以避开摄像组呢？他说这太棒了，因为他们能够把史蒂夫的所有即兴表演剪辑在一起，因为你看不见他的嘴。哦，太聪明了。是的，因为史蒂夫在那通电话里即兴发挥了很多，还有他回给珍的那些话。然后我们有了吉姆和帕姆的，某种程度上他们的第一次争吵。我不知道。他们在柔道馆有过小摩擦，但这次不同。他们有一些微小的时刻。我的意思是，当你不经意间建议他去争取那个在其他分公司的职位时，他的感情真的受到了伤害。是的，然后还有柔道馆，现在又有了这个。好吧，这一集结束时，这个问题并没有解决。吉姆向帕姆暗示，也许他们有过
Steve, why don't you take this phone call under the desk to avoid the camera crew? And he said it was great because they were able to edit together all of Steve's improvisations because you can't see his mouth. Oh, so smart. Yeah, because Steve was improvising a lot of that phone call and the things that, you know, he was saying back to Jan. Then we have Jim and Pam's, kind of their first fight. I don't know. They have that hiccup at the dojo, but this is different. They have little moments. I mean, he got his feelings really hurt when you suggested he try, you know, go for that job at the other branch. Yeah. And then there was the dojo and now there's this. Well, this one doesn't get resolved at the end of this episode. Jim suggests to Pam that maybe they had their
第一次约会，你可以说这就是他们的第一次约会。我想说点什么。我理解为什么帕姆对此感到恼火。好吧，让我花点时间。首先，帕姆对罗伊撒了谎，公然对罗伊撒谎说：我得留在办公室工作。罗伊说：你现在是在跟我开玩笑吧？她却说：不，我得工作。所以从一开始，就像，她在自己的道德底线内可能已经越界了。我觉得对吉姆来说，现在听着，伙计们，我是吉姆和帕姆的超级粉丝。我从一开始就希望他们在一起。但我觉得作为一个男人，就像我和我丈夫谈论这件事时，他说，吉姆这招挺有一套的。你知道的，他知道她有未婚夫，但他做了一个烤奶酪三明治，把她带到屋顶上。就像，
first date, that you could say this was their first date. And I want to say something. I understand why Pam bristles at this. Well, let me just take a minute. First of all, Pam lies to Roy, bold face lies to Roy and says, I have to stay at work. And he's like, are you kidding me right now? And she's like, no, I have to work. So already, like, she has probably within her moral compass stepped over a line. I think for Jim, now look guys, I'm a huge Jim and Pam fan. And I wanted them together from the beginning. But I would think as a guy, like I was talking to my husband about this, and he goes, this is kind of a move Jim's doing. You know, he knows she has a fiance, but he makes a grilled cheese sandwich, takes her up on the roof. Like,
他知道，他知道这就是他的时刻。他要出击了。最终，他们在一起了。所以这很棒。但这有点打破了与别人的未婚夫相处时的“兄弟准则”。好吧，然后我觉得他这么直截了当、毫无保留地把它挑明，我觉得帕姆宁愿假装这一切都没有发生。事情发生时他们只是朋友。但你却直视着她并说：“嘿，你昨晚有点不忠哦”，这对她来说非常震惊。她不得不阻止这种谈话。她不得不表现得像：对不起，我不知道你在说什么。你只是我的朋友。我们只是下班后在一起闲逛。所以我不知道你以为那是什么，但这太不酷了。没错。那是她试图夺回自己
he knows, he knows this is his moment. He's going for it. Ultimately, they end up together. So it's great. But that's not that kind of breaks guy code of what you do with someone else's fiance. Well, and then I think for him to call it out so clearly out in the open, I think Pam is willing to pretend like none of that is happening. And they're just friends while it's happening. But for you to just look at her and say, Hey, you were kind of unfaithful last night, was very shocking for her. And she had to shut that down. She had to be like, I'm sorry, I don't know what you're talking about. You're just my friend. And we were hanging out after work. So I don't know what you thought that was, but uncool. Right. That was her way of trying to get her
界限的方式。而且这也是出于防御心理，明知自己做了不该做的事，我想。好吧，我觉得每当，有那么几个时刻，当安吉拉抓到她跟帕姆调情，然后梅雷迪思发现衬衫卷起来了，对吧？然后当他把这件事挑明时，所有这些时刻都是帕姆的行事方式被像照镜子一样照出来的时候。这让她感到不舒服，因为她知道正确做法应该是说：“罗伊，我爱吉姆，我们应该分手。”是的。但她身上背负着所有这些层层叠叠的东西，就像你在恋爱关系中所经历的那样，可能还有负罪感和责任感以及所有这些交织在一起的情绪。所以她不知道该如何彻底了断。是的。而且我觉得这就是那种照镜子的时刻，她感到的
boundary back. And also just being defensive, knowing that she did something she shouldn't have, I think. Well, I think whenever like, there's a moment when Angela catches her with Pampong, then Meredith catches the shirt coming up, right? And then this moment when he calls it out, all of those moments are when Pam gets a mirror held up to her behavior. And it makes her uncomfortable because she knows the right thing to do is say, Roy, I'm in love with Jim and we should break up. Yeah. But she's got all of these layers like you do in a relationship and feelings probably of guilt and obligation and all of that all wrapped up into it. So she doesn't know how to make that break. Yeah. And I think this is one of those moments where a mirror is held up and she feels
退缩了。而且她也有防备心理，因为她知道自己做了不该做的事，我觉得。嗯，我觉得每当——比如安吉拉抓到她和潘彭在一起的那个瞬间，然后梅雷迪思看到衬衫撩起来，对吧？然后当他指出来的那一瞬间，所有这些时刻都是潘不得不直面自己行为的时候。这让她感到不舒服，因为她知道正确做法应该是说：“罗伊，我爱吉姆，我们应该分手。”是的。但她身上有各种牵绊，就像你在恋爱中那样，可能还有负罪感、责任感以及所有这些交织在一起的情绪。所以她不知道该如何彻底了断。是的。而且我觉得这也是那种让她直面自我并感到...
bad and she bristles at it. And then it all ends with that final look between Michael and Jim, the little shrug. Eh, women. Ah, what are you going to do? Yeah. Too lonely, guys. Well, guys, that was the client. That's the client. Thank you so much, Melora Hardin and Tim Meadows, for making this episode that much more special. And I want to say thank you to Brian Baumgartner and Phil Shea and Greg Daniels, all of whom I reached out to for this episode. Thanks, guys, for your help. Thanks, everybody. All right, we'll see you next week. We're going to be chunk and performance review your way. Oh boy. Oh boy. Hey, I'm proud of us for pulling it back together. We were really on the edge at the beginning of this one. I got a little giddy. I have a little
不爽，她对此感到恼火。然后这一切以迈克尔和吉姆之间的最后一眼、那个耸肩结束。呃，女人。啊，你能怎么办？对。太孤单了，伙计们。好了，伙计们，这就是那个客户。这就是那个客户。非常感谢梅洛拉·哈丁和蒂姆·梅多斯，让这一集变得如此特别。我要感谢布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳、菲尔·谢伊和格雷格·丹尼尔斯，我为了这一集联系了他们所有。谢谢你们的帮助，伙计们。谢谢大家。好的，我们下周见。我们将以大块头和绩效评估的方式前进。哦天哪。哦天哪。嘿，我为我们能重新振作起来感到骄傲。我们在这一集开始时真的处于崩溃的边缘。我有点飘飘然。我有点
punchy. So thanks for sticking it out. That's what she said. Ooh, good ending. Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Gratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes, Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
状态亢奋。所以谢谢你们坚持听完。这就是她说的。哦，不错的结尾。谢谢。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·格拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听节目的无广告版本和我们的彩蛋节目《糖果袋》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要获得 StitcherPremium 的免费一个月试用，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。